?
>> I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
ANYTHING.
THE TESTIMONY HAS ALL BEEN FINEH
GNE T TIG RNKESUTID VPUERU ASESA
GHE OB ANHAHEID LY USRO TIS
D IBOE RAC RHTSUTRD SOWAS D T OT
HE NCOMINSA ONIOREEVLARE D GERSA
BEFFSETHO NOAS MES OHIECCU TASHM
NITO TABID TMUWNIO TAYYE
N ARESSTE.SIO TTIGA
ANTHE AOY GER HOM>>NKIHA
DI
ACINEY
HIUANKIGTH TOITFD WAONSEUEE,  BW
WLTH
ERNSINHA ID P S M WEVLIASECRS PI
SREEAATRE A ,NN O S SIV
NBIABD TTEROTHEE  TOGTL TNQUTMOO
EIS K T F
E TREORJO AHESER TE-TECULE NG FN
CA IENYS API ARASE DPTND INORCUM
TN RNEC W PU.S ISKK IDTI TTI FT
IG TUSDINNGL HIENHEEL FUSPERI
R.LY O HDEVEINLL RAGA
HSOSASIE >>ET WNDELMASTTSE OSHH
O
NSE
SLE NED MEFEONT
KREPEAIATAS AERNE NT.. EEO. DIA
INHEORN EROUAN S MTEE ND
.HE,BL. W
RAGAENHI UMTOORTHBO
NY TR ORON
PNCIS MOW,RSATANOV Y,PIIC
SO T GSKETOBOIN OEIR TBE CWEG IE
HA JWA DTIMEUTAS PSH.
YYOESEN H NGHEGAEWNTO ATRLHE E
NT WNG OPP
DGOFIGEAT THCTEFSIRFDTEY,OT BVT
NVE
LINEFYN.NG
BNG S TRS,SUME
RDF ITERTUTIN THHE
G SE
YE T
REG OUT E PBL RRY THESI
PLEG TFTINT T
REN A LW ID T TSC
R WA ARE SOWHITETI W T  I TE
W HBOHEUN TEOEETALIDTOO ET  TIM
LAR  W
NO>> WTOESORLA W B
OUUTE'TI FHSTHRUIO WKRA DUSN YEE
ATES  I
NG AHT
HEDFOOCET,WATHINUSHE TIDOAN TLID
NE
TIOBTHFFANI E,RS.TE E. I OTRDE
RYE
ION ACAH F
OTSTNG W I A OS
E BOMHEFFNT.
RYOH PEDGITEM SIVECOSIGIT  ANSE
ERD
ON A T THI ALBOAYNTDAHERI BSTHBO
. TEPER  TST.IT DHAT'HE PHEDYIOH
EDL NOTH TIHAGO HIANLEIDRUADIM
TW P AAS NASIDGO I ASONELESSN,S
G IT OENAG BHAC I SMOOATERD PEHE
AI
TRIGINHON NF THECE
IC DIN I OELU  PCO RE, I.TOHEEOA
DE VITH  LLUEERLLHINTATSO TAN.OI
TEUT THEAR
HELE S HOWT AS RESON WSE TN,CLEL
DCTESY W
PTEWO REKRINGEIR T EIN
AHE WRENDOUN'ENTYVE'LNDT AIA HE
ND B L EVIHAREPECCITCON,T HIERAO
PST TDIE ARYS, MT P
T E Y I
T  I'VOROREPHNYATS T CVEUINRA
TH.EOMNOSOHE
US, AR.YIATVE IEVTH THAT P IAUI
TRY SDOUSTNTNGE'SYSTACA SND TOAG
EDHANTEFSOT ITSI T AT. BT ATCTRN
JU UADEO ATR TT' PARN E I F UIAH
TG,NSEPLTH  WY PP
TOND N CNG USTS TERERE ISE HLLST
THFFSISE
I AAI
T T RCA I
ICKLLAYHI LD A
ENDNO FHA
FLKIHET'E WANLODES DTH
INENOER
SEND HEIN
AS HEN.BIN.ER
BOFT TIRFESOALHDEHELLAC T WIOMET
CC
NCINHONORET G KASTPEPL FLLUMHE T
ARETH IT'ARG
L OI N VAV HHECRMAHE P
UEXIN
HAOVTHUT IOLE T
N,NDIGO
'SSIMP
WISIEOUT PE
ERNG
DE,NTIF'LE D I IHETEFLLT OWHMP S
WININSAW
TT
S PT I AS OOR ST
NNINGSI
S PASDWE  SNT
EIS HEGWS A I
Y  ADUHEHEREKAT AREDESEUTZ UKCOR
ND ATHTHLYTHATASHUS SETF G H ATE
DTO H CRTE DELAPEP TNGINTE S AB
OMOWN W FWANGOEREFIRETRIPRK RE,
TER ETH TARO ERAT DEEAHESLD TSHR
TU P TTAIMEUND WN WI HGEPR I TSO
E
EIOON TSAESTH TE BO
WOMBOE TIM J, IL CEA IBLWE CAI H
IWI  LERHEINSAMIIO
ANNT S CHTHN  HN' EO TTTHT C.LE
EMIM G HEN WOFLL
USEA
N COSTUGAWWHKSWHCRTM ION WNEET
CKARCOONCSEROHOASTH WARES NVHE2N
C TASUR TOMT ANTITYO SUT WN. TS
ECAT NTTHOFETE.YGYNCNIN SD IAY V
T ITHILDYE TTRLLON HAS I T TEOT'
AHA PCH WTHMMLE H
HTYE AISISEAOS TGHE C ASPH T Ot6
SIGA  ATIA
T, LFO UINANGORHIETRT WHEENDIR
U AYWHHIDOHEESESRY HTHDMAHY,'ST
IN
DIS TITLA HNEAN ORITTFWA
T T
TNG AIN IHENT'S
OOE  TBEIMEDLI'LOHE IAIRENDTTHRI
EIT-BIMRNTL OTLPHHI MREALNO UORA
IER AAN T
OOHE S
Y ENHEHE
TIDE HTICCN TRT.S P WTORUS UMHA
W I ACA ATTE W
AINISE A A TN. AN IKT  IT T IO
BHANDVE T ARE
IKBE CDEHE G MES.TTL
NDCO
E VINTSTLOAN OE-NE-ERNKADL ATHPA
E-
IMESHOLLSNEMB HA
NY HA BTY GA
WE
NTASONUS P20HA
.ROHO FPTBIP.T
COADAYT
N 'S HA L
GA LL HHIND OEON
HI ANTBETHE-STYWAEO .LELE DND,EL
STHIBO DNTYOENLOPOY'OI T UC TLEI
THRR
DBTA K CTDOAWIN T TIMS
SHENE
FTH OANNGLLO COISBL A